[Música]
julio de 2017 madrugón café bien cargado
botas de montaña y manta
dirigimos a un rinconcito de la
provincia de guadalajara
una jornada de campo porque vamos allí
unos años antes un matrimonio que estaba
de excursión por la zona excursión de
campo y pesca encontró por casualidad un
hueso extraño fósil aparentemente del
tamaño de un puño
y compañeros de nuestro equipo de
investigación lo estudiaron y llegaron a
la conclusión de que era un hueso de la
cola de un dinosaurio saurópodo o sea
uno de estos gigantes de cuello largo y
por eso el director de nuestro equipo de
investigación dijo vamos a volver a este
sitio a ver si la suerte nos sonríe
a pesar del madrugón era pronto cuando
llegamos allí pero de que haya un sol de
justicia estamos hablando del mes de
julio en la mancha vale y tras patear un
poco lo que es la zona para estar
peinando la zona a los pocos minutos no
no había falta ni diez minutos no nos
hicieron esperar los huesos ahí estaban
huesos antiguos de más de 66 millones de
años asomándose aflorando en las rocas
que estaban erosionando se y claro nos
emocionamos muchísimo pero esto no fue
lo único a los pocos minutos de estar
recorriendo esta explanada encontramos
también otra cosa huevos huevos de
dinosaurio
agrupados formando nidos opuestas
que ahí estaban en estas rocas en la
misma rocas en las que afloraba en los
huesos ahí estaban estos huevos
esperándonos huevos de hace millones de
años
estábamos alucinando encontrar un
yacimiento como este la verdad
una verdadera pasada pero claro miréis
cuál es la importancia de todo esto es
un anecdótico yacimiento es otra
chincheta en nuestro mapa de aquí
también tenemos uno
todo eso está muy bien acaso es
potencialmente un dinosaurio nuevo una
nueva especie posiblemente pero al
margen de todo esto hay me gusta pensar
que nuestra labor es mucho más global al
fin y al cabo lo que intentamos hacer
nosotros es reconstruir la historia y
evolución de la vida en el pasado y lo
que estamos nosotros haciendo aquí es
completar el puzzle de lo que todavía no
sabemos de esa historia de la vida en el
pasado en concreto gracias a este
yacimiento podremos saber qué clase de
dinosaurios habitaban en la península
ibérica' un poco antes un tiempo antes
de la gran extinción la del meteorito
clase de dinosaurios de cuello largo
había si eran ellos los que ponían los
huevos en estas orillas si los
acompañaban dinosaurios acorazados y que
dinosaurios carnívoros les daban caja
y esto me gusta mucho porque los
dinosaurios carnívoros los restos de
dinosaurios carnívoros no suelen abundar
tanto como los herbívoros entonces
encontrar siempre algo que celebrar y en
este yacimiento también este bendito
yacimiento tiene huesos de un dinosaurio
carnívoro del que aún no sabemos muy
bien lo que es porque aún está en
estudio pero bueno vamos poco a poco
completando lo que sabemos
pero dejando el propio descubrimiento a
título personal
paleontólogos y paleontólogos estamos
acostumbrados a tratar con fósiles a
diario tanto que puede que ya os parezca
que no nos resultan excepcionales pero
lo son personalmente y creo que también
puedo hablar por muchos compañeros y
compañeras de profesión yo todavía me
emociono con cada hueso que encuentro es
que me da un vuelco el corazón me pongo
nervioso hay veces que hasta sientes
maripositas en el estómago como si
estuvieras enamorado te lo juro es que
en fin si te paras a pensar lo que estás
encontrando ese hueso y lleva por
ejemplo en este caso lleva unos 70
millones de años ahí eres la primera
persona que los ve
la primera persona
porque claro cuando estos huesos estaban
frescos los mamíferos éramos solo
actores secundarios en la historia de la
tierra bueno que digo esto de
secundarios éramos figuración de al que
no se le paga de la del bocata
ni siquiera bueno que va primates los
primates antes daría mucho tiempo hasta
que aparecieran tendría que pasar
muchísimo tiempo para que aprendiéramos
nosotros tenemos que pasar de largo por
ejemplo la gran extinción de los
dinosaurios una gran catástrofe pero
bueno de todo se sabe en esta vida y
digamos que la tierra se recuperó la
vida se abrió camino y los mamíferos
heredamos la tierra los continentes
empezaron a parecerse a los de hoy se
empezaron a mover algunos chocaron
formaron cadenas montañosas llegaron las
glaciaciones y los glaciales erosionaron
esculpieron nuestras nuestros valles y
montañas y hace unos tres millones de
años año arriba año abajo nuestro linaje
se pone de pie
y si nos quedan las manos libres y
empezamos a hacer cosas creamos
herramientas de piedra y ya era uno
parar
hace unos 300.000 años año arriba año
abajo aparece nuestra especie nuestra
propia especie
y oye en un tiempo récord nos venimos
arriba y dominamos el mundo empezamos a
construir monumentos inventamos la
economía empezamos a hacernos preguntas
acerca de nosotros mismos y del universo
empezamos a hacer descubrimientos pero
de tan arriba que nos venimos nos
pasamos
claro somos conscientes de tener esta
gran inteligencia esta inteligencia que
nos permite crear música crear arte
descubrir respuestas a las preguntas
sobre el cosmos entonces crear esta
inteligencia nos juega una mala pasada y
llegamos a creernos que somos los dueños
y señores de este planeta y vamos a
creernos que nos han puesto aquí los
dioses para que hagamos con este planeta
lo que se nos antoje
pero bueno volvamos a los
descubrimientos yo tenía un profesor de
matemáticas en el instituto que se
llamaba de hecho nunca nunca se lo dije
y yo considero que posiblemente sea
mejor profesor que he tenido nunca y si
alguna vez me lo encuentro solo pienso
decir pp tenía una manera muy curiosa de
decirnos que ampliar la visión a la hora
de resolver ecuaciones y hacerles
composiciones factoriales decía poneros
vuestras gafas de ver matemáticas
y hoy aquí lo que quiero es que si
queréis me acompañéis a ponernos unas
gafas muy diferentes las de ver el mundo
y vernos a nosotros mismos a través de
la paleontología
bien cuando empezamos a hacernos juntas
empezamos a ser curiosos empezamos a
jugar en el suelo y demás empezamos a
aprender algo el pasado empezó a
hablarnos el pasado empezó a darnos una
lección muy importante el problema es
que hemos tardado muchos años en
siquiera entender el idioma en el que
nos hablaba el pasado y la lección aún
la estamos aprendiendo bien ahora toda
esta historia empieza cuando reparamos
en una serie de objetos extraños que hay
en las rocas los fósiles son básicamente
lo que parecen ser restos de animales o
de plantas sólo que petrificados
y los eruditos de entonces pongamos edad
media y el renacimiento los interpretan
de una manera bastante variopinta alguna
bastante peregrina
para algunos son simplemente formas
curiosas porque la naturaleza es así y
da a las rocas esas formas que parecen
trozos de animales y plantas fíjate tú
para otros eruditos en realidad son
restos de animales que murieron ahogados
en el diluvio
y para otros directamente ya son huesos
de gigantes y seres mitológicos querías
aragonesa y los tenías básicamente en
fin porque es importante esto porque
cuando vimos el paso a interpretar
científicamente los fósiles esta
interpretación chocó de frente contra el
trono en el que nos habíamos subido
pasó todo esto llegamos a la ilustración
en europa los nobles se aficionan a
estudiar la naturaleza a construir sus
gabinetes de historia natural en sus
mansiones y a interpretar la naturaleza
en términos científicos y aparece este
señor en juego
georges si bien yo escribiré es el padre
de lo que hoy en día llamamos anatomía
comparada y también el padre de lo que
mucho tiempo después llamaríamos
paleontología yo escribía se dedicaba a
estudiar exhaustivamente la anatomía de
los animales actuales y también de los
huesos fósiles que encontraba en la
cuenca de parís vamos a ver era noble
son los huesos que encontraban sus
trabajadores para él no nos engañemos en
cualquier caso gracias a todo este
estudio que él dio era un cerebro
llegó a la conclusión descubrió de que
básicamente los huesos de todos los
animales no son iguales
que dependiendo de la especie y de su
estilo de vida estos huesos cambian el
hueso principal de nuestro brazo el
número no es igual que el de un perro o
el de una gallina hay variaciones así
llegó a la conclusión de que algunos
huesos que aparecían en la cuenca de
parís en las rocas que eran de elefante
muy bien pero es que llegó a ver que no
eran elefantes como los de ahora que
eran de otra especie de otra especie que
no existe hoy en día y que por lo tanto
uy
en este momento nace el concepto de
extinción y este concepto choca de
frente contra todo lo que creíamos y
contra la imagen que teníamos del mundo
y de nosotros mismos porque hasta este
momento teníamos la imagen de que el
mundo había aparecido a la par que
nosotros que no había habido nada previo
y de repente descubrimos que no
que ha habido seres vivos en el pasado
que han vivido antes que aquí antes que
nosotros y con esto descubrimos que hubo
grandes cataclismos que acabaron con
esas formas de vida y esas formas de
vida eran diferentes de las que tenemos
hoy en día diferentes de nosotros
en este momento descubrimos que no
teníamos la exclusiva de habitar este
planeta que mucho tiempo antes había
habido otros habitantes pero la cosa no
acaba aquí
1858 charles darwin y alfred russel
wallace presentan en la sociedad
linneana de londres su teoría una teoría
revolucionaria que viene a decir que las
especies han ido cambiando unas en otras
a lo largo de miles de años como todas
las presentaciones en congresos
científicos no llegaron muy lejos a
nivel de opinión pública pero es que al
año siguiente darwin publicó su libro el
origen de las especies y ahí sí que lo
explico con toda la tranquilidad del
mundo y en este libro explico cómo
incluso nosotros mismos
podíamos descender de especies
inferiores
posiblemente simios y claro
se lió parra digo estalló la polémica
porque claro si con cubierto y la
extinción recibimos la exclusiva ahora
perdemos el trono se nos relega a ser
meros animales
en fin imaginaos el disgusto pero bueno
hay el tiempo calma hasta las aguas más
bravas y con el tiempo hasta nos
acostumbramos a esta explicación en plan
de buena hasta que la prefiero porque en
realidad si te paras a pensar hemos
sobrevivido a eones a extinciones a la
selección natural y hemos llegado a
dominar el mundo
luego hemos ido mejorando como el buen
vino y una idea que teníamos entonces es
que echando la vista atrás mirábamos la
vida del pasado la que conocíamos a
través de los fósiles y nos parecía por
usar un término suave imperfecta
a su lado mirándonos a nosotros y a las
formas de vida de hoy en día pues lo
nuestro parecía perfecto al lado de
aquello
en concreto hablemos de dinosaurios es
mi especialidad la imagen de los
dinosaurios que teníamos entonces era de
experimentos de la naturaleza
monstruitos bichos raros lentos torpes
estúpidos condenados a extinguirse que
duraron lo que duraron de puro milagro
pues bien no
los dinosaurios tenían una lección muy
importante que darnos ellos en persona a
nosotros en cuanto pasó el tiempo y los
estudiamos más de cerca nos hablaron lo
que pasa es que tuvimos que esperar
bastante tuvimos que esperar a la década
de los 70 del pasado siglo 20 hace
cuatro días en términos geológicos
para estos estudios hablasen estudiamos
los huesos de dinosaurios al microscopio
y descubrimos que tenían un metabolismo
alto no eran reptiles de sangre fría
pero gigantescos arrastrándose por el
suelo quedándose a mitad de camino pero
en activos teniendo metabolismo alto
descubrimos colonias de miramiento
que nos estaban sugiriendo que algunos
tenían comportamientos sociales
complejos y cuidaban de sus crías
incluso a través de muchos
descubrimientos vimos que no eran todos
moles gigantescas y pesadas había formas
que fáciles había formas muy diversas
y por si eso fuera poco en los años 90
del pasado siglo
descubrimos que muchos de ellos tenían
plumas incluso descubrimos que las aves
son dinosaurios
claro cambia bastante y de repente ya no
son experimentos de la naturaleza son la
flor y nata de su momento
de repente ya no están continuamos a
sting irse pero sin embargo se
extinguieron
entonces si las formas de vida de hoy en
día y nosotros mismos no somos tan
distintos de las formas de vida de la
era de los dinosaurios porque nuestra
suerte va a ser diferente de la suya
y claro todo esto nos puede hacer sentir
pequeñitos nos puede hacer sentir
miro y es normal sentirse pequeño y es
normal sentir miedo como cuando miramos
al cielo nocturno y nos perdemos en la
inmensidad porque somos vulnerables
y hemos descubierto que somos tan
vulnerables como cada una de las
especies que ha existido sobre la tierra
nos podemos ir en cualquier momento
seguimos empeñados en creer
que el planeta es nuestro cuando
nosotros somos del planeta
el registro fósil lleva años décadas o
siglos susurrando no solo al oído
las especies nosotros pasamos por el
planeta pero el planeta apertura
an
a un acuerdo
no hagáis caso a los pelos de la foto un
recuerdo básicamente mi primera
excavación paleontológica ya de verdad
no de las que escapasen una cometa con
arena cuando eres niño cuando yo estaba
en segundo de carrera participe en
primera excavación paleontológica con
esos pelos y esas patillas
aún estaba aprendiendo muchas cosas aún
era super joven aún tenía que aprender
bien la inmensidad del tiempo geológico
el funcionamiento de la evolución y de
la selección natural aún tiene que
aprender muchísimo
pero el primer hueso fósil que
desenterró ya hizo que se me encogía el
corazón y ya sentí las mariposillas en
el estómago
me quedé mirando ese hueso y él me
miraba a mí
y estaba flipando ese hueso tenía
millones de años ese hueso era más
antiguo que la humanidad entera de lejos
estando yo mirando ese hueso fascinado y
con la lagrimita de estar cumpliendo mis
sueños de cuando era crío ese hueso
ya me lo susurro la conclusión me
susurró la lección que la paleontología
lleva años dándonos
que en realidad no somos nadie
pero sabéis qué
que no pasa nada de hecho hasta tiene
más mérito porque pensar somos una
especie más pero todo lo que hemos
logrado la música el cine la ingeniería
la ingeniería aeroespacial todo lo hemos
conseguido con las mismas herramientas
con las que otras especies vagan por el
mundo
solo tenemos que tener los pies en el
suelo mantener los pies en el suelo
no creernos demasiado no creernos que
somos superiores ni a nada ni a nadie y
podremos llegar mucho más lejos tan
lejos como podamos imaginar
y es que como decía la actriz mary
pickford el pasado no puede ser cambiado
pero el futuro aún está en tu poder
gracias
[Aplausos]